are we going to see some of that drama
on the hype house reality show
you will definitely see all of that
drama on the high pass reality show
what about charlie and chase are they
um the first few episodes of awesomeness
tv's next
influencer are out now for those who
have not seen
it yet how would you sort of describe
what this series is
it's a bunch of it's a group full of
like teenagers in a house where
they're being filmed constantly
partaking in challenges
and trying to stir up the most drama
they can absolutely count
it's a lot of drama i watched the first
two episodes
there's too much drama yeah why
why do you feel like you are the perfect
person
to host this series no plan is part of
the plan it's the perfect plan blah blah
blah
you're not gonna win this competition
you don't say that about a girl
you guys are all trash if there's anyone
that just shut them up
why would you do that with my background
especially with my youtube videos where
it's storytelling and i
kind of make an example of to tell the
best story possible i think that when
it's coming to narrating
such hectic drama in a house full of
teams that's already my job
so it makes it really easy for me to
kind of be
natural in that environment so like for
with my friends i obviously live in the
hype house
and it's i even with a reality show at
that house it's still
not as hectic as mine so
so it was it was pretty easy what does
gabby say is her greatest weakness
oh god i'm talking so bad you talk too
much girl
just because she said that i talk too
much i think that she's so loud like i
think she
like she has a microphone in her mouth
like and she doesn't realize that she
has
she's like this ball of energy that she
doesn't know when to calm down
is there anyone on this show that you're
secretly rooting for
to win or that you think will go really
far i'm rooting for
um shoot i mean i love the twins the
twins are always great
they're gonna they're gonna be amazing
so i'm i'm really excited i love
watching
it back and seeing it what do you think
about coley and owen
are they together do you think that can
never tell with coley i really can't
he was very forward with him yeah no i
know i i
i i'm very excited to see what happens
okay
are we gonna find out you will
is there a happy ending or is it like
does it implode
well you just gotta watch and find out
what do you think makes a good
influencer yeah it's it's so
diverse because i think that there's so
many different categories and
using the term influencer or social
media creator i think that you know
if you genuinely love what you're making
it's going to reflect that to the
audience
i think that you know back four years
ago when it was popular like hey look at
the car i have or hey
you know this is how rich i am and that
was something that so many people wanted
to portray the internet and people found
it interesting and now no one gives an
absolute
sorry but it's it's it's now just
it's it's how can i be as relatable as
possible how can i entertain you for the
longest amount of time and how can i
really
you know make a career out of something
i love yeah if you have that
intention into it then you definitely
will go far but if you're kind of just
going in
to make a bag and a half then you're
sadly mistaken
well what about drama because on this
show i feel like the most
interesting people seem to be the most
dramatic
people do you feel like you have to stir
up drama in some way
for people to care not necessarily i
think that everyone has something to
offer i think the dramatic appeal to it
is just something that is entertaining
to us because you know we love
that society itself loves laughing at
people's mistakes
yeah so i think that drama is very
interesting because it gives us an
opportunity to judge someone else's life
instead of our own
well which do you think is more dramatic
this
series or living in the hype house
alex was having pepper jumping in the
pool in the ball no no no this was his
idea go go go go jump jump
jump jump jump jump
go yeah
it's both the thing the thing here is
with
you know the series it obviously took
like a month to film so like it's it's
you know a bunch of people placed in my
house and filmed
um and then with the high pass it's
definitely um a bunch of people who've
known each other for about five to six
years
who you know you can get pretty sick of
yeah are we gonna see some of that drama
on the hype house reality show
you will definitely see all that drama
on the high pass reality show
have you guys 100 have you guys been
filming that yet
yeah so we have um we started filming
back up again um
later this year or early next year okay
what are we gonna learn
about you and the house when we tune in
to that show um i think that you know
you're gonna learn
about a lot of people i think that so
many especially with this
industry and especially with the job
that we take on you know
what we put out you judge what you what
based on what
is put out about said person i think
that you know this is more of an inside
look on
what happens in the house and how we're
all human i think that everyone kind of
holds
whether i don't i don't think
necessarily tech talkers but i think
in general when people have following on
the internet they're
held to a pedestal and you know made
examples up and i highly agree with that
but also
you know i feel like people are going to
realize that a lot of us are human and
make a lot of mistakes
oh wow is it hard for you to be
that vulnerable and to have cameras
following your every move as opposed to
you know hosting this series
um i think i mean 100 is going to be
more vulnerable i think that you know no
one's used to having cameras on the 24 7
even if my job is to actually do that
you know i think i enjoy a lot of my
alone time and and i don't know how much
of it i'm going to be getting
yeah who all is a part of it do you know
or can you say
it um i don't want to say just yet just
because i wanted to be like you know
surprised because there is some
stuff up our sleeve okay but we're
definitely going to see you on it
you're definitely gonna see me you're
gonna definitely see cover and you're
definitely gonna see some
some of some faces who aren't expecting
will we see
bryce and thomas's issues
potentially play out you'll see the
issues for sure
that's that's a given i think that's
just something that you know
those two i honestly think they'll get
married before me and cover but
i don't know i think that i think that
it's a lot
it's a lot to play out i'm very excited
for the dynamic of that
i am too i feel like everyone watches
that and they're like what
what's happening every day every day
we don't even know what's happening how
do you sort of manage to stay out of all
the
the crazy drama i feel like you have a
good head on your shoulders and you're
pretty
switzerland i'm i don't know i i can't
i'm one
i'm okay so pardon my language but i am
the biggest video i ever made
i'm i'm literally i don't do
confrontation i don't
like i that's how i stay out of dramas i
hate it so much that i will do anything
not to be in it like you know i'm
if if you meet anyone i'm very nice to
everyone like i i anyone who's ever met
me i'm extremely
you know outgoing and stuff just you
know i i prefer to be that way so i feel
like if anyone wants to say anything
about me
it probably would be a lie it just came
to my attention that you want to get
married
look at that away the hundreds of texts
saying marry me i don't know what you're
talking about
is is this your proposal i'm not i'm not
proposing i think it should be no i'm
not marrying you i mean not now let's
talk about a relationship that i don't
think is going to implode and that is
you in cover
yes you guys were doing long distance
i believe for a long time before you
moved out to l.a
yeah i met on snapchat uh two years ago
almost two
i mean a little more than two years ago
and we started talking
around you know november and then i she
flew out to visit
and then i it was for a week and i it
was inseparable i fell
in love with it instantly and i knew i
had to see her
and then i flew out and surprised her
and then she flew out
and decided to stay after that you guys
met on snapchat
yeah and yet they won't give me a damn
brand deal what do you love
most about her being two years and now
and i think you guys are still living in
the same
year yeah we've lived together since the
beginning really we didn't really have a
choice we were kind of
homeless together in cars so i think
that we've kind of
stuck together the entire time yeah what
what is it about her that you think
makes it work
um comfortableness like me and her very
comfortable with each other like it's
not like we feel as if we need to go
and um i feel like i could lay in bed
with her for
a week straight and not get tired of her
so it's like for me it's
it's it's where i'm just like you know i
i love spending every minute with her
you guys are young but like it sounds
obviously mature yeah but her i'm like
serious and she's your best friend yeah
do you think about taking the next step
i'm too young way too young i
with this job already i grow up so
quickly that i'm scared i'm just gonna
i'm miss out on my childhood so i think
that when the time comes it'll be right
you know i plan on marrying her one day
i think that when the time comes though
it'll be right yeah i don't want to rush
into it i think the worst decisions are
made rushed in
yeah you you said you guys
lived together from the beginning
because you basically lived
in cars how do you feel like you guys
have both
helped each other overcome whatever has
happened in your past
and we both had such a big drive i think
that you know we were in such a
tough spot to the point where we kind of
we wanted to make a change in both of
our lives and it made sense
together you know we kind of made the
decision to move in together at such an
early
age but early state in our relationship
because it made sense
not necessarily like oh we have to move
in together it made sense because
we both couldn't afford a place by
ourselves we had to do it together
[Music]
i gotta ask you about griffin johnson he
recently
alluded to the fact that dixie
cheated on him and not the other i'm
friends with both of them extremely good
friends with both of them
so it's you know i'm my biggest thing is
i'm so happy for both of their success
but i'm also extremely
happy for you know their happiness so
if they find happiness i will always
support them no matter what it is and i
think that you know their
relationship sadly was very public and
was ended very publicly but i
i'm glad to see that they've both moved
on pretty well yeah
what about what about charlie and chase
are they bad it's the same thing too i
mean
the only difference between dixie and
griffin and charlie and chase is
the age it's just these kids are so
young you know charlie and chase are so
young and i think also
charlie's one of the biggest creators
ever right now
i think that you know everyone has their
eyes on her and i think there's
some things in life she wants to keep
private and it's very hard when people
cry
okay that's fair i listen i'm just doing
my job but i really respect the way that
you
answer both of those questions and
that's how i stay out of drama
[Music]